[Musique]
il
fils de charles vii le fit orieux et de
la reine marie danjou lyon est né à
bourges en pleine guerre de son temps
issu de la branche direct des capétiens
valois il est enfin reconnue de nos
jours comme un des plus grands acteurs
de la construction de la france moderne
on a parlé d' un fourbe d'un intrigant
personnage extrêmement cruelle en
réalité ce portrait peine sans doute un
à nuancer les écrits de ses
contemporains émanant de la noblesse et
donc souvent peu objectif de sont guère
élogieux mais manque dès lors totalement
de reconnaissance lyon c'est également
un cynique parce que justement il se
fait guère d'illusions sur la nature
humaine est sale conduit parfois à être
inutilement brutale brusque avec les
gens ce qui contribuera à alimenter sa
légende noire
durant son règne de 14 161,14 183 il
prend soin de gouverner en homme d'état
par la ruse et la négociation plutôt que
par les armes en éliminant avec une
infinie patience les grands féodaux
procédé pourtant inhabituel au moyen-âge
pour imposer sa puissance petit à petit
il tisse ainsi sa toile à la manière
d'une araignée la toile france qui à la
fin du règne ressemble beaucoup à la
carte de la france actuelle parmi les
grands rois de l'histoire de france
il faut compter avec l'audience qui ne
s'est dissimulé ne s'est pas régné dans
la construction de la france moderne
rieuse a joué son rôle comme son père
charles vii
il a beaucoup marqué les historiens la
modernité de son oeuvre repose sur le
fait qu'il s'entoure de conseillers de
valeur issue de la bourgeoisie au
détriment de la noblesse et qu'il se
fait proche de ses sujets en parcourant
sans relâche la france profonde et
miséreuse il comprend alors que pour
asseoir la puissance de son royaume
en france et en europe il faut
développer l'économie de celui ci qui
sort exemple d'une guerre de cent ans
dévastatrice tant au niveau de la
démographie que du niveau de vie des
français en général
lyons lui aussi pour agrandir unifiée
organiser le royaume condition première
pour un développement économique rapide
d'où cet acharnement à combattre charles
le téméraire le très puissant ducs de
bourgogne ce qui va rapporter au royaume
de france non seulement la bourgogne
mais aussi l'artois et la picardie
l'acquisition du roussillon de la
cerdagne et du maine anjou relève de
cette fameuse politique toujours aussi
fine qu efficace qui reste l'apanage de
la bile souverain et que nul
spécialistes historiens de nos jours
n'est capable de contester la mise au
pas de la grande noblesse et du clergé
permettent à louis lyons d'amorcer une
transition entre un moyen-âge obsolète
et la renaissance
ses successeurs charles ou 8 louis xii
et plus tard françois 1er vont avoir la
tâche plus aisée car il hérite d'une
france réorganiser administrativement et
en pleine croissance économique
lyon 11 le patient est une dénomination
aussi juste et d'ailleurs plus
communément employée par les historiens
modernes que louis 11 l'araignée pour
qualifier ce monarque atypique dont nous
allons maintenant détaillé le règne il
est très difficile de relater l'histoire
de louis 11 sans s'appuyer sur une
succession de date
une chronologie implacable qui symbolise
ce tissage patient et obstiné de
l'araignée
[Musique]
seul but prendre au piège les grands
féodaux et unifier le royaume de france
[Musique]
marie danjou 20 ans rennes quelque peu
délaissé par le roi charles vii 21 ans
accouche de louis le dauphin le 3
juillet 14 123 à bourges en ces temps
forts triste le royaume de france est en
parfaite décrépitude à la naissance du
futur louis 11 ans 14 123 le royaume de
france est dans une situation très
difficile puisqu'il est partagé entre
deux zones deux obédiences honore la
domination anglo bourguignonne au sud le
royaume de bourges c'est à dire la
partie du royaume qui obéit à charles
vii
en plus de la guerre de cent ans
la france doit faire face à une sorte de
guerre civile entre armagnacs partisans
de charles vii et bourguignons alliés
des anglais à cela s'ajoute la terreur
que c'est ma travers le royaume
les écorcheurs qui pillent incendie
violent et tuent sans relâche ces
écorcheur sont des mercenaires employés
lors des batailles pour compléter les
forces armées des vassaux du roi en
temps de répit
ces soldats sanguinaires se trouve
désoeuvrés et s'organisent en bandeau
redoutable pour commettre toutes sortes
d'exactions
paris est aux mains des anglais charles
vii choisi bourges ville fortifiée pour
mettre à l'abri la reine et le futur
dauphin à la naissance
devant le manque criant de moyens on
opte pour une nourrice une berceuse res
c'est un maître d'hôtel des plus
modestes
très vite on envoie ce petit monde à
loches chateaufort jugé plus sûr encore
que bourges
louis le dauphin séparer ainsi de ses
parents portent alors une très grande
affection à tous cet entourage très
modeste et besogneux et cela va
permettre de comprendre pourquoi quand
il sera roi il va naturellement rejeter
les grands au profit des plus humbles
enfant très solitaire mais très studieux
il reçoit une éducation extrêmement
complète qui va de l'arithmétique à la
politique en passant par la théologie et
les activités physiques nécessaires au
métier de chevalier il est très
difficile de savoir quelle éducation a
reçu le dauphin louis à loches on peut
penser qu'il a été élevé comme le sont
les enfants de france les princes de la
famille royale c'est à dire qu'il a
reçus à la fois une éducation de futurs
chevaliers même si louis on ne sera
jamais un brillant guerrier est aussi
une éducation plus intellectuel coupions
l'opiniâtreté du monde paysan dans
lequel il évolue
il dédaigne le faste inhérents à tout
coup royal il va en être ainsi de toute
sa vie s'est tenue vestimentaire
conforte ce mode de vie et de pensée
on peut facilement creuser le dauphin
puis le roi sans le reconnaître c'est un
atout non négligeable dans la
construction de sa politique
indéniablement sérieuse au service de la
france
[Musique]
grâce à jeanne d'arc qui redonne
confiance à charles vii le quotidien
lugubre des premières années de louis va
changer la situation intérieure du pays
s'améliore et ont permis au dauphin de
rejoindre sa mère et la cour à amboise
[Musique]
à
la guerre de cent ans n'est pas terminé
mais l'étau se desserre la paix d'arras
permettent une alliance avec le puissant
duché de bourgogne et cela va profiter
au royaume de france
c'est le temps où charles vii ne cache
plus ses relations avec agnès sorel
label favorite
louis ne supporte pas de voir sa mère
délaissée très officiellement nous
sommes en 14 139
c'est le moment que l'on choisit pour
marier le dauphin à marguerittes décosse
fille du roi jacques premier est alors
âgée de 11 ans à tours
c'est un mariage politique qui permet
d'affaiblir la puissance du roi
d'angleterre
louis n'accepte pas cette union une a de
cesse de négliger son épouse
on sait par d'ailleurs les deux
tourtereaux car jugé trop jeune pour
consommer le mariage
la dauphine va vivre aux côtés de la
reine marie danjou à laquelle elle va
profondément s'attacher
[Musique]
charles vii entreprend cette même année
un voyage en dauphiné et dans le sud de
la france
il emmène son fils à des fins
démonstrative de la puissance royale
depuis peu retrouvé sauf que louis va
s'initier très vite aux problèmes de
politique générale qu'occasionne ce long
déplacement à travers la france cela
revêt lé en lui des talents de
gouvernance ceux dont le père est loin
de se douter il assiste aux assemblées
diverses écoutent avec attention se
montre curieux de tout remarque avec
acuité l'état de misère dans lequel se
trouve le sud de la france
il constate aussi la mollesse
décisionnel de son père c'est à cette
période que louis commencent à se méfier
du roi les rapports entre le père et le
fils n'ont jamais été bon ce sont deux
zones de pouvoir dont l'un le détient et
dont l'autre aspirent à le détenir leur
différence d'âge n'est que de 20 ans ce
qui signifie que le dauphin va devoir
attendre vraisemblablement longtemps la
succession et il semble que l'ensemble
de sa politique retorse de la suite de
son règne proviennent de cette
adolescence difficile
cela va conduire à des mésententes
notoire voir des affaires graves proche
de la trahison d'état le tout accentué
par la grande intelligence du dauphin
néanmoins adolescent fougueux et hyper
actif il participe à la prise de la
ville de château landon et en retire
autant d'orgueil que considération de la
part des chefs militaires de son père
[Musique]
dans la foulée en août 14 137 il assiste
au siège de montereau puis entre dans un
paris en liesse aux côtés de charles vii
il se découvre l'envi de régner au plus
vite et les événements qui vont suivre
vont en témoigner de retour en touraine
il continue de délaisser sa jeune épouse
très dépressive à laquelle il reproche
décrire plus de rondot que de donner des
héritiers à la france il reçoit alors sa
première grande mission personnelle
pacifier le languedoc en proie à des
troubles multiples mettant aux prises
les grands féodaux du moment en peu de
temps par la négociation par la ruse par
la menace d'emploi de la force
il parvient à rétablir l'ordre et à
organiser une administration des
finances tout dévoué à la cause royal la
réussite est indéniable ils réclament
alors à son père la gouvernance de ce
qui lui revient de droit
le dauphiné son père ne consent que
partiellement à sa requête
lorsqu'il et intendant du dauphiné là à
ce moment là il est à nouveau tout en
mettant quelques formes diplomatique
dans une opposition à son père parce que
il rend le dauphiné très indépendant il
créer une université il fait venir des
banquiers juifs il avait le sens du
développement le centre des affaires
c'était un grand administrateur
c'est le début d'une sorte de trahison
ou pardon et punitions alterne obéissant
à la raison d'état
[Musique]
le dauphin 17 ans en 14 140 la
gouvernance partielle du dauphiné ne lui
suffit pas il a des griefs nombreux
envers son père ait plus rien désormais
ne les rapproche surtout pas
l'impatience du fils à prendre enfin les
affaires de la france en main les
exploits guerriers du dauphin louis sont
assez restreints il a participé à
plusieurs campagnes militaires contre
les anglais qui tiennent encore une
partie du royaume mais aussi contre son
propre père quand il soutient le
mouvement de révolte qu'on appelle la
pra grille en 14 140
louis reproche à charles vii son
inaction politique
l'humiliation qu'il fait subir à sa mère
en privilégiant sa favorite
agnès sorel qu'il déteste copieusement
charles 7 va aussi priver les grands
féodaux lors des états généraux
d'orléans de la possibilité comme par le
passé de gérer eux mêmes leurs armes et
qui doit désormais être réformé pour
n'avoir qu'un seul chef
le roi de france la prague rice était
une fronde comme on en verra après
au début du règne de louis xiv une
fronde avant la lettre et c'était déjà
des seigneurs des aristocrates
rassembler contre l'autorité de charles
vii et bien le futur louis 11 le dauphin
en a fait partie
les grands féodaux alexandre de bourbon
charles 1er et louis de bourbon la
tremoille jondeau d'alençon dunois forme
d'une ligue qui doit destitué le roi il
placer son fils afin de restaurer les
droits bafoués de la noblesse
louis se laisse entraîner dans cette
sale affaire car il a soif de pouvoir
mais le complot échoue lamentablement
charles vii fait alors preuve de grande
mansuétude et pardonne à tous sauf à
alexandre de bourbon qui est enfermé
dans un sac et jeté dans la rivière aube
charles vii pardonne ses forces
honnêtement de former son fils au métier
de roi il lui confie des missions
militaires dans le cadre de la guerre de
cent ans il ne charge de reprendre le
port de dieppe en 1443 ce donc dauphin
s'acquitte avec succès et surtout
l'année suivante il lui confie une
grande expédition militaire dans l'ouest
du saint-empire germanique à la demande
de l'empereur qui est l'occasion de
rétablir l'influencé française dans une
région où elle a beaucoup décliné les
relations du dauphin louis avec son père
charles vii deviennent de plus en plus
difficile à tel point qu'en 447
louis est envoyé dans le dauphiné c'est
à dire la région dont il est le prince
en tant que dauphin
c'est à dire la région de grenoble qu'il
va gouverner jusqu'en 14 156
là il va faire preuve d'une grande
efficacité dans la réorganisation
administrative de cette province et
montre un talent réel de futurs hommes
d'état mais ce n'est pas la dernière
contestation du fils vis à vis du père
à cette époque le dauphiné est une
principauté qui n'a pas de cohésion
territoriale
c'est une mosaïque de petite seigneurie
très indépendante surtout les
seigneuries épiscopale et le premier
soin du dauphin louis en arrivant sur
place c'est d'obtenir l'hommage de tous
les seigneurs du dauphiné même les
seigneurs qui ne sont pas ses vassaux et
par suite d'obtenir la collecte sur
toutes les terres dauphinoise même
celles qui ne sont pas des fiefs
relevant d'une aux fins de l'impôt que
vote l'assemblée représentative du pays
les états de dauphiné ce qui lui
permettra d'améliorer ses recettes
louis le dauphin fait du dauphiné un
véritable état indépendant
de ce fait il se rapproche du puissant
duc louis de savoie et épouse même sa
fille en 14 151 charles de sa voix
contre l'avis de charles vii
allier 10 forza et du duc de bourgogne
le duc de savoie est un ennemi sournois
du roi de france
c'en est trop pour charles vii qui prive
son fils de sa pension royal il veut
jouer depuis sa petite principauté
un rôle sur la scène internationale
entre la france lempire dont le dauphiné
fait toujours formellement parti
d'italie et ça le lance dans une
politique dont sa principauté n'a pas
les moyens ce qui finit par susciter un
large mécontentement parmi les
dauphinois et lorsque finalement en 1456
charles vii envahi le dauphiné avec une
arme et son fils ne se fait aucune
illusion sur la volonté de résistance
des dauphinois à son profit louis fui le
dauphiné et se réfugie chez le duc de
bourgogne philippe le bon âge enap
cette fois il n'y a pas vraiment de
pardon le roi meurt avant en juillet 14
la france est un pays puissant
victorieux et jouissant d'un grand
prestige à travers l'europe à
l'intérieur duquel le roi a exploité son
image de prince victorieux pour prendre
la main sur les grands féodaux et
rétablir l'autorité centrale
c'est une fin de reigne glorieuse
puisqu'en 453 les anglais ont été
définitivement chassé du royaume mais
c'est aussi un pays encore convalescent
qui n'est sorti de la guerre de cent ans
que depuis moins d'une décennie et où la
reconstruction économique va prendre
encore des décennies
très vite
louis rentrer en france et se fait
couronner à reims en août 14 161 moins
d'un mois après la mort de son père
d'aucuns disent encore que charles vii
est mort d'empoisonnement
[Musique]
l'avènement de louis ix 11 est prévue le
15 août 14 161 sans perdre de temps
son hôte d'exil tout puissant et
narcissique ducs de bourgogne philippe
lebon entreprend de prendre en main le
déroulement des opérations
cela va permettre à ce dernier de
montrer de manière ostentatoire sa
puissance et sa grande richesse
cela ne plaît guère aux futurs rois mais
rusé il laisse faire celui qu'il appelle
par flatterie excessive
son oncle philippe lebon est un homme
face tu veux un mécène qui a bien
compris que les arts la culture la
littérature peuvent être des armes au
service de sa politique d arme de
propagande des armes qui permettent de
magnifier la grandeur de la maison de
bourgogne
quatre mille cavaliers en tenue de
parade quitte la flandre suivi d'une
intendance qui dépasse l'entendement
sur le chemin qui mène à reims ville du
sacre des rois de france
le peuple ébahi devant tant de
déploiement de richesse applaudi ne
sachant d'ailleurs pas vraiment qui est
le roi s philippe lebon en habit de
lumière ou celui qui le côtoient vêtu
minablement comme à l'accoutumée
toujours est il que ce long déplacement
permet déjà à louis ii constaté dans
quel état de misère se trouve la
paysannerie
au sortir de la guerre et des exactions
des écorcheurs il réfléchit en
chevauchant et il est probable que son
impatience à renier et imposer sa
politique vient de cette émotion
fortement ressentie devant la pauvreté
philippe de bourgogne va donc payer les
frais du sacre mais il en est le metteur
en scène le sacre se déroule selon le
rituel habituel et louis daigne de temps
en temps se montrer gracieux mais il
semble que cela lui coûte
la couronne a déposé symboliquement par
le fier ducs de bourgogne et les
festivités peuvent commencer
mais cela ennuie louis qui aspire à ce
que cela cesse au plus vite
il veut rejoindre paris au plus tôt et
se débarrasser ensuite de la compagnie
de son richissime protecteur pour
commencer un règne en adéquation avec la
conception qu'il a de la politique au
service de son pays et de ses sujets ils
gardent en tête en particulier la clause
qu'il a fait rajouter sur le formulaire
de serment lors du sacre accroître le
royaume
le 30 août 14 961 ils entrent dans paris
et comme à reims le grand-duc officie
dans le faste pour éblouir les parisiens
en liesse lyon se prêtent de moins en
moins à tous ces rituels festifs
il commence vraiment son travail de rois
ils s'attachent à manipuler tantôt en
achetant en séduisant tantôt en menaçant
et en brutalisant en particulier
contrairement aux ducs de bourgogne ce
grand pragmatique ne croit pas à
l'efficacité de la plume et du pinceau
pour tenir les zones pour tenir les
esprits pour lui ce qui importe c'est de
tenir les corps et pour ça rien de
voleur et le faire des armes on achète
on conquiert on menace on soumet ce sont
les fondements de sa politique
il désire changer au plus vite
l'administration de son père peut-être
pas règlements de comptes mais surtout
dans un souci de recherche de personnes
compétentes en phase avec la réalité
économique et géopolitique du moment
c'est l'épuration des cadres grand
officier parlementaire gouverneur bailly
en matière d'administration toutes les
réformes sont odieuses finalement
l'aspect par lequel il rompt le plus
avec la pratique politique de son temps
c'est sans doute son autoritarisme
personnel et sa propension à décider
seul et à maîtriser les qu'on fait c'est
cela surtout qui lui est reproché car
dans la culture politique du temps le
bon roi est celui qui consulte qui prend
conseil avant de décider celui qui ne
consultent pas c'est le tyran très vite
ils se lassent de la vie parisienne et
retourne se ressourcer en touraine son
avènement permet d'amnistié bon nombre
de prisonniers dont le poète truand
françois villon
[Musique]
le domaine royal a certes retrouvé un
peu de grandeur sous charles vii
notamment avec le départ des anglais
cependant beaucoup donc l'avant pêche
l'unité de la france
mais seules deux maisons sont gênantes
la bretagne et la bourgogne la bretagne
est un duché à part qui fonctionne en
autonomie totale et n'a prêté allégeance
au roi de france que du bout des lèvres
et sont jamais appliquées véritablement
ce serment françois 2
leduc craignant est d'abord angle fils
c'est cela qui obsède louis 11 de plus
la bretagne est un pays grâce à sa
langue et ses coutumes
le duché possède son propre parlement sa
propre chancellerie sa propre armée son
propre clergé sa faiblesse est une
richesse toute relative
avec une économie tournée vers la mer
la bourgogne est un duché d'une autre
envergure très peuplée très riche au
niveau agricole très important au niveau
commercial
il comprend aussi au hasard des
alliances matrimoniales habile la
flandre le luxembourg la zélande
lyons crainte une annexion de ces
provinces par philippe le banc dans sa
tête la soumission totale du duché de
bourgogne reste la priorité de sa
politique d'unification du royaume de
france
la politique extérieure ne préoccupe pas
louer 11
même si l'angleterre rêve de reconquête
aucun traité ne sanctionne la fin de la
guerre de cent ans
même si les turcs eux se montrent
menaçants en europe même l'italie est
instable
le roi c'est d'attendre observer et
analyser son intelligence politique et
son habilité vont très vite faire leurs
preuves en espagne pays à l'heure
divisée en quatre royaumes turbulent
aragon castille portugal et navarre la
mort de dawn carlos primo génique
d'aragon et ami de louis 11 va permettre
au roi de france 2 réalisé un premier
exploit diplomatique payant pour l'unité
du royaume de france rendant le roi jean
2 d'aragon responsable de la mort de
dawn carlos et répondant à un appel des
catalans qui demande sa protection
il va obliger le roi d'aragon à négocier
il impose agent 2 le legs de la navarre
à sa fille eléonore qui est marié à
gaston de foix
ainsi la navarre pastel sans l'emploi
des armes sous domination française
dans un même temps des querelles
naissent entre jean d'aragon et henri iv
de castille
le traité de liszt et une entente entre
louis 11 et le roi jean ii d'aragon qui
est confronté à la révolte de ces sujets
catalan il débouche sur un accord
d'assistance militaire mutuelle qui
stipule que celui les deux rois qui va
requérir l'aide de l'autre devra payer à
l'avance la solde de l'armée alliée
concrètement jean 2 à besoin de l'aide
de l'armée française pour réduire la
révolte de la catalogne mais ça lui
coûterait des centaines de milliers des
cuisines en absolument pas les moyens et
il va donc accepté d'engager à la place
jusqu'à un éventuel paiement
les deux comtés catalan au nord des
pyrénées que sont le roussillon et la
cerdagne et c'est ainsi que louis 11
après les avoir occupées va non
seulement prendre possession de ces
comptes et met les annexer purement et
simplement
contrairement au traité de son alliance
avec jean ii au nom du droit de conquête
c'est le traité d'olite ainsi commence
le patient tissage de l'araignée
parallèlement à ces actions dans le sud
de la france
lyon se soucie aussi du nord il
manoeuvre habilement et navigue si l'on
peut dire entre 3 au tantôt roland
castres pro york et pro reine déchue
marguerite d'anjou ainsi s sa vision de
la guerre des deux roses
il profite aussi de la vanité du
désormais sénile duc philippe le bon
allié des anglais pour racheter les
villes de la somme tél amiens saint
quentin doullens le crotoy et bien
d'autres mais ce rachat mais charles de
charolais fils de philippe lebon hors de
lui une lutte sans merci va reposer à
partir de là charles que l'on va appeler
le téméraire alloué 11
cette guerre va durer dix ans et entre
dans la légende de l'histoire de france
[Musique]
il faut rappeler que pour gouverner loup
et 11 ne s'entoure que de gens de
modestes origines il entend priver les
grands féodaux de leur grand privilège
pour imposer une autorité ne pouvant
venir que du roi poursuivant
consciemment la politique des grands
rois capétiens saint louis et philippe
le bel ces rois capétiens voulait à tout
prix montrer au peuple une image de
justice de force et montrer qu'ils
étaient supérieurs aux seniors aux
aristocrates is voulait beaucoup plus
près du peuple qu'elle était aristocrate
on pourrait dire qu'il jouer le peuple
contre les aristocrates
[Musique]
cela ne convient guère à ces grands
personnages charles duc de berry et
frère du roi jean ii de bourbon françois
2 de bretagne jean ii d'anjou et surtout
charles le téméraire il publie un
manifeste nommant charles régions de
france
la riposte de louis 11 est immédiate et
contrairement à ses habitudes il est
contraint de mener une guerre entre mars
et juin 14 165
les armées rivales se rencontrent à
montlhéry
la bataille est rude et meurtrière
chacun des deux camps se proclament
vainqueurs
surtout charles le téméraire lyon c'est
quand même contraint de gagner paris où
il organise une résistance au siège de
la ville en clair ils laissent pourrir
la situation et entreprend des
négociations séparées
le traité de conflans avec charles le
téméraire il redonne les villes de la
somme et son frère duc de berry
il lui donne le duché de normandie le
traité de saint maur avec les autres
grand noble leeger auxquels ils
concèdent quelques babioles le traité de
caen avec le duc de bretagne françois 2
qui reçoit étampes et montfort mais il
s'est déjà dans sa tête qu'il ne tiendra
jamais content de ses concessions qui
lui permettent de gagner un peu de temps
pour affronter le véritable rival
charles le téméraire louis 11 met à
profit la mésentente entre son frère
charles duc de normandie et le duc
françois ii de bretagne pour reprendre
la normandie mais la mort du duc de
bourgogne philippe lebon donne les
pleins pouvoirs à charles le téméraire
alliés des anglais puisque marié à
marguerite d'york un risque non
négligeable de retour à la guerre de
cent ans trotte dans la tête de loup et
il lui faut une nation soudée
la convocation des états généraux la
première depuis bien longtemps est une
manoeuvre politique de louis 11 qui
souhaitent s'appuyer sur la communauté
du royaume face à son frère charles de
france qui réclame un apanage aux ducs
de bretagne et aux ducs de bourgogne
qu'ils soutiennent le monarque récolte
les fruits de sa politique qui
privilégie les gens du peuple au
détriment de la haute noblesse
la réunion est très encadrée elle dure à
peine huit jours et les états se
séparent après avoir condamné d'une part
l'occupation de la normandie par le duc
de bretagne et d'autre part recommandé
au roi de ne pas constituer à son frère
un apanage trop important et c'est
exactement ce que voulait louis 11
les gens du peuple préfère la
gouvernance ferme du roy pour empêcher
le retour d'une guerre ruineuse et
inutile pour la prospérité du royaume
charles le téméraire accepte un mariage
politique avec marguerite d'york ce qui
renforce l'union de la bourgogne avec
l'angleterre
cela ne sied point louis 11 il sait
charles à la fois hypocondriaque
chevaleresque et orgueilleux il se méfie
donc des réactions à l'emporte-pièce du
puissant duc à la fin de la guerre du
bien public trois ans plus tôt il avait
dû faire d'importantes concessions à
tous les princes et particulièrement aux
ducs de bourgogne qui te vient bientôt
charles le téméraire à la north son père
philippe lebon dans les trois années qui
ont suivi il a patiemment chercher à
grappiller à reconquérir les avantages
qu'il avait concédées en particulier les
droits de justice où les droits fiscaux
sur les terres bourguignonnes situé à
l'intérieur du royaume
ce qui avait suscité des conflits
croissants avec charles le téméraire
peron c'est une histoire assez compliqué
parce que les typiques du duel de
l'opposition très longue entre louis 11
et philippe lebon de bourgogne et puis
ensuite de charles le téméraire tous ces
gens étaient cousins fip le moins cher
le téméraire et descendez aussi il était
de la dynastie capétienne était c'était
la branche bourguignonne et valois
séjour se disputer pour savoir qui était
le cas était le chef et
le roi de france voulait imposer son
autorité d'été obligé de le faire par
les voies diplomatiques parce qu'il
n'était pas sûr de gagner sur le plan
militaire
[Musique]
profitant des fastueuses fête célébrant
le mariage de charles à bruges
lyon 11 attacks françois de de bretagne
et le contraint à signer le traité
d'ancenis ce qui oblige le duc à rompre
l'alliance avec le téméraire des
ligueurs il ne reste plus que la
bourgogne et cela libère l'horizon
politique du roi de france
apprenant cela charles le téméraire
devient furieux louer 11 propose alors
une rencontre afin que l'on s'explique
entre hommes le risque est grand
compte tenu du caractère de charles mail
ou et 11 reçoit la parole d'honneur du
duc affirmant qu'il ne pourra rien lui
arriver quand louis 11 est allé à
péronne discuter avec charles le
téméraire charles le téméraire s'est
aperçu et ça c'était tout à fait dans la
dans la politique de louis 11 que tout
enfin dans l'enfer une mission de bons
offices à péronne et bien louer on
devait attaquer des possessions en
flandre dépossession bourguignonne et
donc charles pépin s'est senti floué il
tombe en fait dans un piège et charles
le téméraire lui arrache plusieurs
concessions importantes dont la
souveraineté sur le comté de flandre un
traité stipule la neutralité de la
bourgogne en cas de conflit avec
l'angleterre et la champagne en apanage
à charles duc de berry et frère du roi
un incident majeur survient alors les
liégeois sous protectorat français se
sont révoltés et ont massacré des
proches de charles qui voit là une
perfidie de son interlocuteur du moment
sa colère est incontrôlable il retient
lui onze prisonniers
[Musique]
cependant après quelques jours de fureur
non contenue charles se rappelle de sa
parole d'honneur et doit trouver une
issue il oblige le roi a signé le traité
et le somment de l'accompagner à liège
pour le châtiment mérité avant de
recouvrer la liberté
il est obligé d'accompagner charles le
téméraire dans une campagne punitive
contre la ville de liège qui s'est
révolté contre le protectorat
bourguignon avec les encouragements de
louiron c' est le roi de france doit
assister en personne à l'écrasement de
ses alliés en criant vive bourgogne
louis 11 accepte sans broncher
liège est détruite mais louis est libre
il est parfois difficile de juger la
raison d'état cependant l'honneur du roi
se trouve fortement entachée cet épisode
du million va profondément atteindre le
prestige du roi de france à l'étranger
où certains de ses alliés se détache de
lui comme le roi de bohême et à
l'intérieur même du royaume où son
autorité s'en trouve affaibli
lorsqu'il s'est retrouvé libéré
évidemment il a tout de suite contesté
ce traité inégale et à ce moment-là a
repris de plus belle cette opposition
très dur entre entre les deux cousins et
cela va nourrir une haine de louis pour
charles qui va aller crescendo
la préoccupation première de louis 11 et
de ne pas respecter le traité de péronne
charles de france son frère est un homme
médiocre et forte influençable s'il
devient duc de champagne comme le
souhaite le téméraire la jonction entre
la flandre et la bourgogne sera alors
effective et le grand duché ne fera plus
qu'un géographiquement louis 11 après
maints de pressions menaces ou fausses
promesses donne à son frère la guyenne
il ne reste plus aux rois qu'affaiblir
les relations amicales des anglais avec
le duc de bourgogne
il se sert pour cela de richard de
neuville compte de warwick qui l'aide
sans vergogne dans son entreprise visant
à renverser le roi edouard iv
d'angleterre et faire libérer de la tour
de londres henry 6 le mari de marguerite
dans jours exilé en france
la sphère réussi dans un premier temps
mais edouard iv reconquérir son trône
cependant son pouvoir se trouve affaibli
et ne lui laisse aucune latitude pour
lancer une armée en france pour soutenir
éventuellement charles le téméraire la
mort de charles de france accélère alors
la perte du duc de bourgogne charles le
téméraire qui accuse lui onze d'avoir
empoisonné charles de france décident de
lancer une offensive en normandie afin
de rejoindre les armes et bretonne de
francs soit 2 et monter une coalition
contre louis 11 au moment de l'attaqué
bourguignonne sur le front nord en 1472
louis 11 avait prédit que la première
ville forte qui parviendrait à retenir
le duc de bourgogne suffirait à briser
l'offensive et c'est ce qui s'est
produit à beauvais c'est au cours de
cette féroce tentative de prise de
beauvais que s'illustre jeanne line est
plus connu sous le nom de jeanne
hachette
elle repousse à la hache un bourguignon
venu planter l'étendard de charles le
téméraire sur les murs de beauvais
la prouesse des beauvaisienne est
cependant réelle et louis 11 les
récompenses après l'échec de la prise du
téméraire en leur permettant de
s'habiller comme les femmes de la
noblesse et en organisant tous les ans
une procession où elles marchent devant
les hommes
[Musique]
charles le téméraire s'est obstiné à
faire le siège de la ville alors qu'il
n'avait pas les moyens de l'isoler
totalement ce qui a permis à louer 11
d'envoyer renfort sur renfort à
l'intérieur de la ville et en même temps
d'encourager les bourgeois de beauvais à
la résistance par d'importants avantages
fiscaux
cet épisode de beauvais précipite la
chute de charles le téméraire qui s'y
frotte s'y pique ne cesse de répéter et
louis 11 la trêve consécutive à l'échec
de beauvais amène charles le téméraire
vers d'autres horizons très incertain il
s'empêtre alors dans une entreprise
folle de conquête allemande abondamment
encouragé par louis 11 et six espions
recrutés à cet effet le duc s'enlise en
guerroyant et en tentant des
négociations avec l'empereur frédéric
iii
il veut devenir roi de bourgogne il
échoue
une inutile aventures guerrières en
suisse pour mater une révolte alsacienne
soutenu financièrement par louis 11 ne
rencontre pas plus de succès
l'armée bourguignonne s'affaiblit et
louis 11 le patient jubile il travaille
en toute discrétion à la levée d'une
armée de vingt mille hommes au cas où
l'angleterre ambitionnerait à nouveau de
reprendre les territoires perdus après
la guerre de cent ans
effectivement edouard iv d'angleterre
débarque en mai 14 275 à calais mais les
troupes alliées bourguignonne ne sont
pas au rendez vous occupé à mater les
suisses et les lorrains le roi
d'angleterre en prend ombrage et ne
comprend plus rien à la stratégie de
charles le téméraire
lyon profite pour négocier la paix avec
les anglais le traité de pikine y est
concluant 14 175 il permet à lyons
d'acheter le départ d'une expédition
anglaise qui avait débarqué dans le nord
du royaume
c'est le fameux traité de picquigny qui
met réellement fin à la guerre de cent
ans une trêve de 7 ans et signé contre
l'octroi d'un tribut de 75 mille écus
une rente annuelle de 50 mille écus au
roi d'angleterre bikini va permettre à
lyon de neutraliser le roi d'angleterre
edouard iv jusqu'à la fin de son règne
le roi edward va continuer à comploter
contre lyon a passé des alliances
antilles françaises avec ses autres
adversaires seulement l'appât du gain la
perspective de ces dizaines de milliers
des culs déversées chaque année dans ses
coffres et qui représentent une part
notable du budget royal anglais à
l'époque va toujours le retenir de
passer à l'acte cela paraît peu glorieux
pour le roi de france
mais l'achat de cette paix permet de
garder intacte une armée qui le cas
échéant viendra facilement à bout de
charles de bourgogne
contrairement à la plupart des rois de
france lyon ce n'est pas un roi comment
dirais-je belliqueux il n'aime pas se
battre les p o point c'est bien que bon
comme il faut quand même qu'ils à
soissons son trône qui est son royaume
et bien il ne va pas le faire par la
force il va faire par la ruse
j'ai plus aisément chasser les anglais
hors du royaume que ne l'a fait mon père
car mon père les a mis hors à la force
des armes et je les ai chasse et à la
force de pâtes et de venaison et de bon
vin leduc se trouve désormais bien seul
et consentent à une trêve de neuf ans
le traité de soleuvre habilement louis
11 le laisse alors s'obstiner à punir
les récalcitrants suis est lorrain et le
team piège du souverain français charles
le téméraire prend la ville de nancy et
promet d'en faire la capitale de son
futur royaume
mais ils restent menacés au sud par les
suisses qui ne désarme pas et qui sont
d'ailleurs grassement subventionnées par
l'araignée une expédition punitive
hivernale en pleine montagne la manière
d' animal tourner à la déroute pour
l'armée bourguignonne à grand son et
morat les nombreux espion de louis 11 le
tiennent informé la toile d'araignée se
termine cette image de la reine
l'universel à règne qui est présente
partout a été forgé par la propagande
bourguignonne ce sont les chroniqueurs
officielle des ducs de bourgogne qui ont
ainsi stigmatisé les méthodes de louis
ix oms tissant passionnant sourdement
sournoisement sa toile autour de ses
adversaires pour les enserré dans un
réseau d'informateurs de partisans est
d'allier à cet animal ignoble d'eau sans
citer mme hawley timo logique c'est à
dire non nobles les chroniqueurs
bourguignon oppose le lion qui est le
duc de bourgogne roi des animaux animal
noble et prestigieux par excellence dans
la propagande bourguignonne la lutte de
louis 11 et des ducs de bourgogne c'est
la lutte de l'araignée et du lion
charles le téméraire accumule les
maladresses il fait enlever yolande de
savoie la soeur de louis et se
discrédite totalement aux yeux des
savoyards louis 11 fait récupérer sa
soeur et obtient traité d'alliance
perpétuel avec la savoie qui laisse
entrevoir d'autres perspectives de
récupération territoriales c'est aussi
le moment choisi par les lorrains de
reprendre leur autonomie
cela agace charles et bien qu aux abois
il met le siège devant nancy
mais la fin est proche rené staller en
lui ses instincts chevaleresque il veut
mourir les armes à la main
c'est chose faite le 6 janvier 14 177 sa
mort sur le champ de bataille marque la
fin de son aventure il éduque depuis
quatorze 167 et pendant dix ans il a
mené une politique militaire très active
qui se termine donc dans la catastrophe
le corps nu et lacéré de blessure du
téméraire est retrouvé dans la neige est
il mort au combat at il été assassiné à
la mort de rené d'anjou qui avait
soutenu charles le téméraire louis 11
conformément au testament signé à lyon
14 176 avec son oncle fait appliquer les
clauses du document le royaume de france
s'agrandit donc de l'anjou et du maine
de la provence avec louis 11 la trahison
se paye cash
lyons peut récolter les fruits de sa
non-intervention armée hormis cette
drôle de bataille de guinée gâte de 14 à
177 qui l'oppose à maximilien d'autriche
et aux personnes ne sort véritablement
victorieux
les négociations compliquées qu'il
engage avec marie de bourgogne fille de
charles le téméraire et edouard iv
d'angleterre abouti c'est un véritable
triomphe
la paix d'arras permet au royaume de
france de récupérer l'artois la picardie
la franche comté et la bourgogne
[Musique]
cette succession de dates résume le
caractère implacable d'une politique
tout aussi implacable à la manière d'une
araignée patiemment d'année en année
lyons tisse une toile appelé france peu
de faits d'armes glorieux mais une
gouvernance tout en subtilité y amène le
royaume de france
au niveau de ses frontières actuelles
lyon 11 est un monarque éclairé
il s'appuie sur les gens du peuple et ne
rechigne pas à renier la grande noblesse
ainsi que le clergé
seule la raison d'état prévost
l'histoire ancienne le présente comme un
roi cruel
sans doute car il ne supporte pas les
conspirations et des trahisons mais
attention à l'exagération des images
d'epinal lyon c'est également un cynique
parce que justement il se fait guère
d'illusions sur la nature humaine est
sale conduit parfois à être inutilement
brutale brusque avec les gens ce qui
contribuera à alimenter sa légende noire
lyon avait fait fabriquer des cages pour
y mettre ses ennemis ses rivaux ceux qui
ne voulaient pas de bien celle de loches
par exemple on le sait a servi au
cardinal là bas lui qui avait eu tort de
de s'allier à quelques ennemis du roi
alors c'est vrai qu'elle existait ses
cages
mais d'abord on se tient bien droit à
l'intérieur on n'est pas goûté bossu
quand on en sort
et puis les prisonniers ni étaient
hébergés que nuitamment pendant le jour
il avait le droit de se promener à
l'intérieur du château sous surveillance
bien sûr mais on dormait en cage
[Musique]
on dit de lou rihon ce qu'il est fourbe
il vaut mieux dire que c'est un habile
négociateur un fabuleux manipulateur un
orateur convaincant un marieur
impénitent un observateur attentif à la
moindre faille de tout interlocuteur
en bref un être particulièrement
brillant intellectuellement peu enclin
aux fastes et aux tenues vestimentaires
d'apparat il aime néanmoins la bonne
chère et les bons vins dont il est grand
connaisseur la politique très ferme de
louis aux très sévères lui a permis de
gagner une grande adhésion populaire
ce n'est pas un monarque à favorite même
si on lui connaît deux maîtresses ce qui
est peu pour un roi de france
feliz de regnard et marguerite de
sassenage
il a avant mariage très certainement des
aventures avec derribo de passage lors
de ses nombreux déplacements
son premier mariage avec marguerite
stuart décosse reste anecdotique
cependant il semble être assez fidèle à
charlotte de sa voix sa deuxième femme
et mère de ses enfants de france
cavalli infatigable il parcourt
inlassablement le royaume
mais en réfléchissant même temps il sait
parfaitement communiquer avec le tiers
état il développe le commerce
l'agriculture l'industrie les grandes
foires des grandes villes en sont le
témoignage il parfait la puissance et la
modernité d'une arme et enfin royal le
règne de louis 11 se termine sur un
bilan fortement contrasté avec de belles
réalisations
la destruction de la maison de bourgogne
après la mort de charles le téméraire en
14 177 lyon se récupère alors le duché
de bourgogne et la picardie avec
d'autres belles réalisations comme
l'acquisition de l'anjou du maine et du
comté de provence
mais louis 11 laisse aussi un royaume
épuisé par une fiscalité très importante
et par une vision paranoïaque de la
politique
la fin du moyen-âge en france ce n'est
pas la prise de constantinople où la
découverte de l'amérique mais la fin du
règne de louis 11 il laisse un royaume
puissant redouté de ses voisins un
royaume où à l'intérieur l'autorité
royale est très forte et incontesté
toute opposition aristocratique a été
brisée mais il laisse aussi un royaume
souffrent car ces résultats
spectaculaires ont été atteints au prix
d'une flambée des impôts qui écrase les
français alors même que les dernières
années du règne sont marquées par une
succession de cas d'un mythe est
naturelle et d'épidémies en définitive
on peut dire que le roi louis ix on
laisse une france grande et des français
malheureux il légua sa fille
la régente anne de beaujeu puis à son
fils charles ou 8 un grand royaume
administrativement organisé prospère et
moderne une de ses citations résume à
elle seule la pertinence de sa pensée
politique
en politique il faut donner ce que l'on
n'a pas et promettre ce que l'on ne peut
pas donner